afternoon everyone I'd like to welcome
you as well as our good friends from
c-span to the McGowan theater located in
the National Archives building here in
Washington DC I'm Doug Swanson visitor
services manager for the National
Archives Museum as well as the producer
for the noontime lecture series before
we begin today's program I'd just like
to remind you of a few other programs
we've got coming up in the near future
on Thursday March 16th at 7 p.m.
Damien shields will present a lecture on
the Forgotten Irish Irish immigrant
experiences in America this will be the
u.s. book launch of the book and there
will be a book signing following then on
Wednesday March 22nd at 7:00 p.m. will
present a film screening and discussion
of following seas which is presented in
partnership with the DC environmental
film festival to find out more about
these and our other programs please take
one of our monthly calendar of events
which you'll find in the racks in the
theater lobby or you can visit our
website at www.archives.gov/calendar for
The Wall Street Journal his first book
the president and the assassin McKinley
terror and the Empire at the dawn of the
American Century was a Newsweek magazine
must-read summer selection as a
journalist Miller spent nearly two
decades in Asia and Europe reporting for
more than twenty three reporting from
more than 25 countries including two
postings in Germany which the backdrop
which is it back to upper age at 1:10 he
has appeared on The Daily Show with Jon
Stewart National Geographic Channel CNBC
and Britain Sky News he also holds
degrees in economics and communications
and earn a Master of Philosophy in
international relations from the
University of Cambridge please join me
in welcoming Scott Miller to the
National Archives
[Applause]
next up I thought what I would do today
is talk a little bit about kind of the
background behind this book how I came
to write it introduce you to some of the
characters along the way and then
describe a little bit about sort of the
final product and then we'll have time
for questions and any comments that you
have afterwards I will readily confess
that I did not set out to write this
book I was originally very interested in
the early days of Americans involvement
in the Vietnam War that whole period was
always held an interest for me you know
really right after the war the French
involvement in Indochina it also seemed
like a subject that hadn't been done to
death already so I began to do a little
bit of research and I happened to cross
these two characters there there those
are the Dulles brothers Allen Dulles is
in the lighter colored jacket he was
director of the CIA during the 50s and
during the period I was interested in
and the gentleman in the dark suit is
his older brother John Foster Dulles who
was secretary of state when I found
these two guys I thought boy there's got
to be an interesting story here it's an
interesting time in American history
there's two brothers and I thought
there's got to be a sort of a good
relationship there's got to be some good
way of telling that story so I really go
then I discovered pretty quickly that
Allen the guy in the light-colored
jacket had been in Switzerland during
World War two
where he was a station chief for the
Office of Strategic Services and there
he was given code number 110 and
immediately my interest kind of perked
up I've always been a little bit of a
world war two geek
and probably more importantly I've
always been a frustrated ski bum and we
lived in Germany where I was a newspaper
correspondent and pretty much every
weekend that we could we'd head down to
Switzerland and hit the slopes and
thought of doing a book they took place
in Switzerland really captured my
imagination Allen also became a very
interesting figure for me he was born to
a very patrician American family he had
two relatives who were secretaries of
state he had served in the State
Department early in his career he had
quit that job to make more money and
went to Wall Street so he got a law
degree and worked at the law firm
Sullivan and Cromwell and it really kind
of got interested in the kind of the
idea of the gentleman spy he had a very
little bit of espionage experience when
he was sent off or really what was a big
job in Switzerland so at that point kind
of my focus began to shift and I thought
maybe there's a story really just to do
with what Allen was up to in World War
two but I still needed a lot more
information and I was particularly
particularly concerned and interested to
find out what sort of sort of
subordinates characters there might be
that would help Rand out the story very
quickly I discovered
there's a picture of Alan and
Switzerland you can see the Alps in the
background and it looks like you've got
a tennis court there he's accompanied by
his number two in the OSS Bureau very
quickly I discovered this woman
that's Mary Bancroft now Mary came from
the same sort of family that Dulles did
she was from Boston her father had been
publisher of The Wall Street Journal she
had married a American figure skating
champion who competed in the 1928
Olympics but she left him for what she
described as a purely physical
attraction to another man and it turned
out that Mary had a real eye for the
gentleman and she ended up meeting a
Swiss fella by the name of Jean
ruefenacht and they moved to Switzerland
she admitted that she didn't really love
Jean but she was really interested in
his personal story at least the story
that he told her Jean claimed that he
was part Turkish it was entirely a lie
he did it just to get Mary's attention
and Mary loves sort of the sense of
danger and adventure that she imagined
Turkish people entailed and so they
ended up getting married they moved to
Switzerland where Mary sort of threw
herself into Swiss society she had a
very outgoing and extroverted
personality I think there was at times a
little bit of spark with her neighbors
um you know sort of reserved Swiss work
the sort that immediately took to her
but she soon met there's a picture of
Mary in Switzerland she met a lot of
notable people including the famed
psychiatrist Carl Jung and she met um
when she developed a sort of weird sort
of affliction and she the whereby she
would start sneezing when she was in
socially awkward situations and so she
took this too young who was able to cure
her and she was very much impressed by
young also I think she developed a
little bit of a crush on him
she left a quote where she said that she
fell him one hell of an attractive guy
and she kind of wormed her way into a
group of people who spent a lot of time
with young and began to study his work
she became pretty well known especially
among Americans in Switzerland and they
recruited her pretty early when they saw
the war was coming to do various jobs
kind of State Department jobs looking at
German speeches and writing them up
writing newspaper articles that were
favorable to the American government
when Dulles arrived they introduced her
to Dulles and he immediately asked her
to join his team and she came to sort of
assume a fairly important role and what
Dulles was doing and then very suitable
for my purposes and telling a good story
she became Dulles his mistress and so I
thought you know here's a here's a good
character she brings a lot of dimension
to the story and really flushes it out
then I kept looking and I came across
this guy Metz hans bernd cos a vyas now
he's a German he's a bit of a Hulk of
the man he stood six foot for everybody
who knew him describing is being
insufferably arrogant and difficult to
deal with he had risen through the
German security and police services and
he'd been in the Gestapo in the very
early days his career in the Gestapo
didn't go very well he was a real
schemer and a plotter and he decided
that he could advance his career by
spreading a rumor about the head of the
Gestapo told people that he thought he
was a communist now that didn't go over
very well because ABS got drummed out of
the Gestapo and was actually luckily he
wasn't thrown in jail but he was able to
land a job in another arm of the German
intelligence services called the obverse
and this was a group that they basically
did intelligence for the German military
and Goo's aliases attitudes toward the
Germans and towards the Nazis
was rapidly changing at this point in
the Gestapo he had seen how nasty the
Nazis could be and I think also of
course he would never admit it and I'm
just my supposing here but I sure get
the feeling that he was just kind of
pissed off that his career hadn't gone
as well as he hoped and so he began to
plot against the Nazis they sent him to
Switzerland
where he immediately reached out to the
British who were very skeptical
skeptical of him and he tried to
establish contact with the Americans who
were also pretty worried I mean he was
not a very trustworthy guy at best he
was a double agents and you don't really
want to put a lot of confidence in
somebody like that but he quickly met
Dulles and Dulles was willing to meet
him and they developed a good
relationship now for me this was perfect
aside from these two characters what was
really good was that both of them
survived the war and that they wrote
about their experiences Mary wrote an
autobiography which was published in the
80s she left unpublished versions of it
at Radcliffe University including her
Diaries and all sorts of really valuable
information because a vs2 wrote an
autobiography who worked on it during
the war and what made it really
interesting was that it turned out that
Mary helped him write it she was the
fact that she did so was one of Dulles
'iz schemes he wanted to learn as much
as he could about his alias and so
working with Mary he asked her to help
him translate the book and to work on
bits and pieces of it and so he produced
a very it wasn't entirely accurate in
places but it was an insightful account
of what it was like to work with Dulles
and so at this point I thought okay
there's good characters there's a good
story it's a good time I just have to
figure out kind of what the narrative
thread is what's the what's the plot to
this book there were lots of great
anecdotes and spy stories but I felt
like they didn't really link
so at first I tried looking at dulles
--is antipathy towards the Soviets and
as you might remember at this time the
United States was an ally of the Soviet
Union and they were supposed to be our
friends
but Dulles didn't buy it and he spent a
lot of the war warning in the United
States and anybody who would listen that
the Serb that the Soviets weren't to be
trusted and they really were aiming to
dominate Europe after the war so I wrote
actually some of the book along those
lines
and I showed it to my editor who thought
you know that's a good idea but maybe
there is a better one looking at the
activities of the resistance and I sort
of did what any good author or
journalist would do when the editor
makes a suggestion I immediately thought
you know surely that can't be true if it
was it was good I would have thought of
it by now it turned out my editor was
dead right hmm
there was a really good story to tell
with the resistance and best of all the
story of the resistance really sort of
moved and dovetails very closely with
what Dulles did and Dulles worked with
him
so that really sort of led us to book
that book that we have now there's a
picture of Dulles taken about this time
he always had the pipe with him
everybody always talked about that does
arrived in Switzerland in November 1941
or 1942 rather his cover and everybody
had some sort of cover he traveled under
his real name and everybody knew his
that it was Allen Dulles but his
official explanation for being in
Switzerland was that he was a special
assistant to the American mission the
head american head of mission in Barren
he claimed and I think probably
correctly so that he was the last
American to enter Switzerland before the
Germans sealed off the border and he was
really in a lot of ways marooned there
during the war he couldn't leave for
several years he wasn't able to receive
much help from the OSS a few agents were
able to sneak through
from Italy but he didn't have a great
deal of interaction with them so it was
sort of a bit difficult for him this is
the house that he selected he lived on
the first floor which also served as his
office and he chose this particular
locations picture was taken I think
around 1933 and it's in the old quarter
of Barron on a street called the Heron
Gaza and he chose it specifically
because there was a busy shopping street
on sort of other end of the Heron grass
here in Gaza so there was a lot of foot
traffic going back and forth and he
figured that would provide cover for
people who were coming to visit him
there at the at the front door the
occasionally saw what he suspected were
German agents across the streets and
monitoring the comings and goings even
better was that this house you can't see
it in this picture but the back yard
slopes down gently towards a river and
it was covered with a vineyard and a lot
of his contacts would come up by night
he turned off the lights and they would
come up through the cover of the
vineyard to knock at the back door and
he was able to meet a lot of people that
way without anybody who was monitoring
the front knowing what he was up to
Dulles arrived in Switzerland with some
contacts he'd been in the in the
American diplomatic corps and in the
legal profession he knew some people and
he was able to look him up right off the
bat and found out some interesting
things but it was really going to be a
pretty slow slog to build up the kind of
network that they wanted to achieve so
he employed a couple of techniques one
was simply to buy intelligence Dulles
brag to everybody about how well
financed he was and word quickly got
around Barron which was a very small
town particularly among Lee the
diplomatic and and spy
a British agents once remarked that
Dulles me as well as put a sign on the
front door that said intelligence
purchased here
another technique that Dulles employed
was to simply meet everybody who came
along you know normally somebody is
setting up a spy ring a station chief
would shows some discretion before he
would meet somebody trying to feel them
out and find out if they were going to
feed him bogus information or if they
were even dangerous but not Dulles this
was from a lesson that he had learned
during World War one he had been in
Barron
one Sunday afternoon he was in the
American mission there and the phone
rang and somebody called up and said you
know I really need to talk to an
American diplomat now Dallas loved to
play tennis and he loved young ladies
and that afternoon at a tennis date with
an attractive one so he said that is a
male call back on Monday and Dulles
later learned that the person who called
that day was Vladimir Lenin and he never
learned what Lenin had to say but it was
a lesson that he took very much to
hearts and he talked about that
throughout his career about the
importance of not prejudging anybody
so with that Dulles was able to sort of
rapidly get to know people and kind of
applying his women principle it enabled
him to meet this guy I'm sorry the
picture is a little bit has some
imperfections his family gave it to me
and it's you know got a little bit of
wear and tear over the years that is
Fritz kolba he was a German member of
the foreign ministry we had kind of a
low level position he was essentially
kind of a clerk but by the end of the
war he became what was probably
America's most important intelligence
asset during the entire war he was a
dedicated anti-nazi and in
anti-bolshevik and I think he also had a
real taste for adventure you like the
idea of being a spy and so
his position offered him an opportunity
to see a lot of top-secret German
documents the German all three branches
of the German military would update the
Foreign Ministry with what they were
doing and he had an opportunity to read
these documents and kind of decide what
was passed on to who so he started
coming into the foreign ministry on
Sundays when it was quiet and everybody
was at home and he would take notes on
these top-secret documents in almost
unreadable handwriting and you can
imagine the stress he was under probably
writing as rapidly as he could and he
started collecting these documents but
he really didn't have anybody to give
him to he had a friend in Switzerland
who at one point reached out to the
Brits who weren't interested the the
British had recently been fooled by a
similar offer and they'd lost two agents
and this looked like you know a similar
ruse and they were not going to fall for
it so Colville was able to make contact
with Dulles shortly after Dulles arrived
they had a midnight meeting in an
apartment and Baron and Dulles was at
first skeptical but Koba produced about
a hundred and eighty documents on that
particular day including ones that
described German codes he talked about a
German agent that was operating in
Ireland and one of the coolest things
was a map of Hitler's headquarters on
the Eastern Front and he sketched it out
that evening for Dulles just on a little
piece of paper and said here's where
Hitler holds his briefings there's a
railroad tracks here's the theater you
know the whole thing and you can see
that little piece of paper at the
National Archives up in College Park
it's really cool by the end of the war
he supplied the u.s. with about I think
two thousand documents and undertook
tremendous risks and you know despite
some having zero training and
intelligence and transporting these
documents back and forth to between
Berlin and
switzer Lindsay originally he tied the
copies he made copies and to simply tied
them around his leg with twine under his
pants to get him to Switzerland he later
developed more sophisticated techniques
but he ended up surviving and the Nazis
never figured a match it was an amazing
accomplishment what really got Dulles
a--'s interest though was the stories
that gazania stoled him about the German
resistance and the underground now at
first Dulles was quite suspicious of
Gizeh vyas the guy was a German agent
after all but they were meeting together
one afternoon when evening actually and
in the Herren gossip that we just saw
the Heron gasa Dilla a couple of red
leather chairs that were in Dulles
office and they were having a drink and
gus' atheists reached into his pocket
and pulled out a little black book and
in this book or from it he read a
top-secret american cable that had
recently been sent from switzerland to
washington and there was no way that the
germans should have been able to get
their hands on this let alone been able
to decipher the code and Dulles couldn't
believe it and this is obviously very
revealing and worrying information with
this knowledge the Americans started
using the the code they knew the Germans
could read descends bogus information to
kind of confuse the Germans and of
course they changed it for their their
real correspondence but the real
importance of that was that Dulles came
to really trust gazania so the fact you
could read your enemy's codes was not
something that you gave away so what
Dulles learned from gaza vyas was that
there were two fairly distinct
resistance movements operating in
germany one was led by members of the
german military
this rather this guy despite his rather
sour expression is Ludvig back he had
been the chief of staff of the german
army
until 1938 when he resigned in protest
over Hitler's ambitious plans he was he
represented quite a number of very
senior German officers who were opposed
to Hitler and wanted to do something
about it he also learned that this
character Carl Girdler who had been
mayor of Leipzig was a member of this
group
gord ler was an eternal optimist he kind
of offset the cold realism and sometimes
the negativity of the officer corps he
was probably too optimistic for his own
good he was a bit naive that did not
serve him well in the end and members of
the this group also worked most
interestingly I think with Wilhelm
Canaris he's a guy he's in the trench
coat with sort of the fur lining the
shorter one there in the centre of the
screen and Canaris was the head of the
odd bear the military intelligence now
he had started the war in the early days
and he was a Hitler backer like a lot of
people were in the early days because
Hitler was trying to make up for the
horrible treaty as their sign but as the
war went along
Canaris really learned to hate the Nazis
and he began to use his position as had
to be up there to plot against the Nazis
and he carved out a number of important
jobs in the odd therefore people who
were trying to overthrow Hitler and
hatching plots against him it was you
know it's an amazing thing here we are
in the center of Berlin center of her
intelligence and there's a little nest
of people who are trying to overthrow
him it's really a remarkable story
Dulles also learned that there about the
second group which was led by Helmut
James Graf von Milka now if there's any
sort of hardcore
military historians out there you'll
recognise mochas being a very famous
name in German military history MOCA was
a law
by training he opposed the Nazis from
the earliest days and he set up a group
called the cries out circle this
organization was very different from the
group of officers they were younger they
were much more eclectic there were
journalists there were members of the
foreign ministry academics they were
much more liberal they initially had a
lot of qualms about whether it was
morally right to kill Hitler maybe maybe
a coup would be okay but was it really
morally correct actually murder somebody
they met in small cells around Germany
and had discussions about what sort of
economy or political system Germany
could have after the war one of the
really interesting things that they did
was they tried to avoid writing things
down for security purposes but when they
did they took them to mochas estates in
the German countryside and they hid them
all in a special compartment in a
beehive which I thought was a great
place to keep secret documents you can
imagine any police coming around taking
a look at a beehive and thinking you
know I'm sure that's fine
Dulles learns something really important
from both these groups and that was that
they really wanted American help in
deposing Hitler not so much in actually
trying to kill him or any secret
operation that they wanted a promise
from the Americans that they would treat
Germany well after there was a coup or
after Hitler had been replaced they all
remembered how horrible it had been
after World War one and how vindictive
they felt the Allies had been towards
Germany and they weren't going to risk
their necks deposing Hitler if it was
going to be the same thing all over
again
Dulles was unable to offer those
assurances and so the resistance did
everything they could to try and
convince the Americans to know their
sincerity they were very clever they
started initially by playing to Dulles
as well known
hatred of the Soviet Union and they said
you know if the Americans don't help us
I'm sure that Moscow will and they began
supply Dulles with information that
suggested that witches it was legitimate
but it certainly served their needs
despite this they despite the fact that
the US wouldn't help them they continued
with their schemes and probably there
were several really interesting attempts
to knock off Hitler they came in really
close and the Hitler had an amazing
instinct for avoiding assassination or
avoiding coup I mean it's just
incredible how many times during the war
he was able to escape the resistance
moved forwards towards a clocks which
was hatched on July 20th 1944 this is
the famed Valkyrie operation it was led
by sort of a relative newcomer to the
resistance klaus von Stauffenberg and
he's on the far side of this photo he's
in the light color jacket standing at
attention
Stauffenberg had always very much
opposed Hitler and had decided the only
way to get rid of him was to murdering
and I don't know I won't go into it in
great depth unless you want to later on
because I think it's reasonably well
known there was a movie called Valkyrie
a couple years ago with Tom Cruise who
actually bore quite a resemblance to
Stauffenberg Hitler survived that attack
as I said he was injured and people were
killed in it but Hitler survived and
what followed was really it was bad for
the resistance and it was bad for Hitler
from Bedford Dulles rather in the weeks
and months that followed thousands of
people were rounded up around Germany
and hundreds were executed including
many members of Dulles circle of
informants and for a time that really
sort of didn't look very good for Dulles
Bancroft talked about how unhappy he was
and the life had kind of
on out of his life and he wasn't quite
sure where it was all heading kind of by
late 1944 he was receiving a lot of
surrender offered from various German
officers or representatives of them
don't really kind of dismissed those
they all looked pretty self-serving you
know attempts by people to sort of save
their own neck and Bellus really kind of
wondered what would happen to his his
station all that changed in the very
first part of 1945 Dulles was at home in
the Heron Gaza one morning and it
received a phone call from a friend and
Swift intelligence who said that Karl
Wolfe who was a general in the SS he was
in charge of the entire SS for Italy was
then in Switzerland and was on his way
to see Dulles now this was pretty
shocking news Wolfe actually had with
him a small entourage of people they had
reserved two cars on a regular swished
passenger train and they pulled the
blinds down and in both the cars so that
nobody could see him the trip didn't go
particularly well on that particular day
an avalanche swept down across the
tracks and blocked his train he had to
get out with all the other members of
the German team marched through the snow
and get on a regular Swiss passenger
train where they risk being seen
breck them he did succeed in seeing
double that night they met at a
safehouse that the OSS maintained in
Zurich and Wolff made a couple of
startling declarations to Dulles first
that he was willing to surrender the
entire SS force in Italy to Dulles which
was that alone was pretty tantalizing
but he also said that he was buddies
with Field Marshal Albert Kesselring who
was in charge of the German army in
Italy now this was pretty explosive
stuff they were talking about
the surrender of a million men and the
end of an entire front and even more
important from Dulles and the Americans
perspective was what it meant for
fighting in the Alps and in the closing
stages of the war the Americans had
convinced themselves really entirely
wrongly that the Germans were going to
make a last final stand in the mountains
of Austria and Italy and there was lots
of intelligence that suggested that
Germans were building factories and
hollowing out tunnels and even building
air conditioning and some of these
factories there was a special commando
unit that was being established called
the werewolves that is a great name for
a commando unit I think now if I said it
turned out it was completely wrong the
intelligence was bogus and the written
Americans really fell for a kind of a PR
scheme that Joseph Goebbels brought up
but it really paralyzed American
thinking there the Americans
estimated that if there was some sort of
guerrilla war and the outs that it could
drag World War two out by two more years
and it promised to be very bloody
fighting all the advantages that the
American military enjoyed were kind of
nullified in the mountains and so when
they saw an opportunity to you know in
the fighting in Italy and capture these
troops or achieve their surrender that
was something that they had to jump on
you can see in this slide there's Dulles
and his number two shields of governance
looking at a map of Italy the only
problem was that the Soviets found out
pretty quickly that Dulles was talking
to senior German officers I think it's
fair to say that Stalin pretty much blew
a gasket he had spent the entire war
worrying that the US and Britain would
cut some sort of secret deal with German
and that the three of them would gang up
on him and this looked exactly like the
sort of thing that he had feared all
along there were what followed were
weeks of bitter transmissions between
Stalin and Roosevelt's were stalin
accused the Americans of operating
behind their back and Roosevelt tried to
calm him down but Roosevelt kind of got
irritated and a lot of historians kind
of looked to these exchanges as sort of
the beginnings of the Cold War another
problem was that Wolff grossly oversold
his position with Dulles Kesselring
really was not interested in
surrendering in Italy and finally in
sort of most dangerous for Wolff was
that Heinrich Himmler the head of the SS
in Germany found out that he had been
talking to jealous he essentially took
Wolf's family hostage back in Germany
and said you better get your tail back
here and we're going to have a pretty
serious chat about what you've been up
to
so with considerable trepidation Wolff
went back to Berlin got chewed out by
Himmler and kind of their talk ended
with Wolff being ordered to go see
Hitler himself that evening Wolff left a
very interesting account of going to see
Hitler late in the war down in the
Fuehrer bunker which was the underground
sort of fortress bomb shelter that
Hitler lived in and Wolff kind of spread
his story that was part true and partly
he said yeah I've been meeting with
Dulles he figured the Germans had
figured that out but he said it wasn't
really to surrender it was really to cut
a good deal for us some sort of peace
deal between Germany and the United
States and he claimed that Dulles had
the ear of Roosevelt's and thereby he
could communicate directly with
Roosevelt so Hitler's sort of calmed
down and he thought that maybe that was
a good idea and in the latter months of
the war that was kind of Hitler's main
hope for how the war would end was
the Americans and the Soviets would have
some sort of falling out he really was
never convinced that the Communists and
the capitalists could really get along
for very long so he sent Wolfe back to
Italy Wolfe said he was just happy to
get home with his head still on his
shoulders and to begin new negotiations
with Dulles those talks sort of dragged
on for several weeks and there are all
sorts of sort of misadventures and false
starts but they finally agreed a
surrender of German forces which took
place on May 2nd and Dulles was pretty
fired up about that he had achieved
quite a feat fortunately a sort of a lot
of the accomplishment diminished when
the entire German army in Europe
surrendered 5 days later but it still
was being full Wolff had no doubt
treated American prisoners of war better
than he would have it refused to destroy
telling artworks or telling factories
because he was talking to Dulles and and
it did in five and five days early and
you know probably saved hundreds if not
thousands of American lives
Dulles stayed on in Germany after the
war he became the station chief for the
OSS in Wiesbaden which is just up the
Rhine a little bit from Frankfurt but in
his heart really wasn't in it he kind of
disagreed with American occupation
policy the Americans after the war had
laid down very strict rules that
basically barred anybody who had been
associated with the Nazi Party from
participating in occupation government
and Dulles really didn't agree with that
policy his prime concern as always was
the Soviet Union and he wanted to make
sure that Germany really got back on its
feet and was stable politically and
economically and it you had to turn to X
Nazis to achieve that that was the price
you had to pay he once said that
you can't even make the trains run in
Germany on time without the help of
ex-nazis they'll spend a lot of time
sort of not really managing the staff
that was assigned to him and most of his
attention was given to what he called
the crown jewels these were people who
had worked with during the war he wanted
to make sure that they were well looked
after
um kolba who we saw a few minutes ago
was particularly well looked after he
was given a car and food rations and you
know basically nobody had a car in
Germany right after the war so that was
that was something Dulles eventually he
left Germany in the fall of 1945 an OSS
was disbanded he returned to his law
practice at Sullivan and Cromwell in New
York and he still was pretty much living
in the past other lawyers there said
that he remained very fixated on the war
and spent as much time as possible
reminiscing with old friends who had
come by he got very active in the
Council on Foreign Relations and kind of
used that platform to argue for treating
Germany well and not trying to punish it
excessively for the war he also advised
Congress on establishing a new
intelligence service to replace the OSS
and what eventually became CIA and of
course he became the first civilian
director of the CIA in 1953 but that
concludes my prepared remarks I'd be
happy to try and answer any questions I
guess if you want to ask you need to
make your way to a microphone which is
on either side there's one over there
and one over there
so yes sir all right what happened to
Mary Bancroft
that I'm glad you asked that question
because I have a bonus slide for that
very question and that is married there
with her legs crossed and she's sitting
with clover Dulles who was Dulles his
wife and it turned out that clover came
to Switzerland and joined Dulles well
the war was still on and Dulles being
Dulles his wife they didn't they had an
unhappy marriage I think it's safe to
say and clover sometimes kind of God in
his hair so he asked Mary can you you
know become buddies with my wife and
take care of her
which was a pretty bold move but berry
volunteered and clover pretty quickly
clover was quite astute and she figured
out pretty quickly what had been going
on
she told Mary you know I I know what's
been up to and I think the quote was
something like and I have proof but she
and and Mary became pals
so they both were very interested in the
young and studied his writings and in
the closing dates of the war they even
took a tour sort of on the northern
border of Switzerland to kind of look
across into Germany and Mary wrote about
their trip together and you know all the
horrible things they could see in in
Germany may actually remains friends
long after the war Mary moved to New
York and she continued to study young
she wrote some books and she wrote the
autobiography of a spy about her
experiences in the 1980s but she was
always felt I wish I could have met her
but she seemed like a really interesting
character somebody was really
comfortable in her own skin and always
spoken mind
anyone else
so the station chief you know they
mentioned you mentioned the Germans were
outside did people actually know his
actual role how how long did it take
before everybody said Oh duh of course
he says OSS - that's a good question it
didn't take them long to figure out that
he was in Germany but there had been a
newspaper article that was written in a
Swiss newspaper
shortly after Dulles arrives and that
newspaper article said that this guy
Allen Dulles is here is kind of a
well-known diplomat and the newspaper
article said that he was a special
emissary from Roosevelt which was
slightly different from Roosevelt's
cover story and Dennis was at first
horrified that there was a newspaper
article about him but he kind of
realized pretty quickly that you know if
people want to believe that I'll let
them and the Germans bought that they
wrote a rather lengthy report some I
think it was in January or February of
1943 just a few months after he arrived
saying that Dulles was there and it had
a biography of him and they had found
some Germans who had known him from
before the war and they said he's in
Switzerland and he's just here on
Roosevelt's behalf and we think he's
really most interested in the German
economy you know gathering intelligence
about the German economy it really
wasn't sort of late very late in the war
before they kind of figured out that he
was OSS they really sort of clung to
this mistaken identity they know that he
was doing some espionage but they really
didn't know that much about his his
network there was a a report that the
Germans did after Valkyrie in the summer
of 1944 and they mentioned Dulles as
somebody who had been working with the
German resistance so you know they had a
pretty good idea whether he what he was
about and what he was up to but
certainly they were lacking a lot of the
detail
how did how did Dulles get the
information he was gathering back to the
United States so that they could take
advantage of it that was a constant
problem they had originally because
Switzerland was surrounded by the
Germans and the occupied territories
Italians on all sides they originally
experimented by giving documents to
diplomats from neutral countries who
would smuggle it out of the country
through France and you know to Spain
which was neutral and they could fly it
out from there
but those documents tended to go missing
from time to time so that didn't work
very well they experimented they would
transmit some things just over the
telephone and they knew that the Swiss
Intelligence Service was monitoring
their telephone lines and the Swiss
really monitored everybody that the
Swiss knew that there were a lot of
spies in their country and they were
kind of willing to look the other way
but they wanted to know what everybody
was up to and there were people in the
Swiss intelligence service who were
pro-american and there were some who
approached durman and so you really
couldn't transmit very much secret
information over the telephone so Dulles
used a very simple code that he would
send things back and forth on on by
telegram the problem was that decoding
was was always difficult and the Swiss
helped him out quite a bit with that
there were quite a number of German
pilots and aircrew who had been found
their way to Switzerland which was
neutral maybe they had crashed along the
border and it's not going to Switzerland
or sometimes if a plane developed
mechanical trouble they would land in
Switzerland and the Swiss wouldn't
return them to the US but they allowed
them to stay in their country and Dulles
as I said mentioned during the talk had
some friends and Swift intelligence and
so they let the air crews work with
Dulles on a lot of the coding of the
secret documents latter later in the war
this was one of the coolest things that
they thought of they were getting a lot
of microfilm of secret documents from
Germany they convinced a
a railroad engineer who went between
Lyon France and Geneva to build a
special compartment in his train and it
was kind of near the boiler and so they
would put microfilm or documents in the
secret compartment and it actually had a
little lever on it and so if the train
was ever inspected the conductor could
hit this lever and whatever was in this
compartment would fall into the flames
of the boiler and be incinerated and you
could avoid detection and so those
documents would go to France where it
was met by members of the French
underground who bicycles it down to the
Mediterranean and they took it by boats
to a location that was eventually flown
to London where it was looked at and
then sent on to Washington but they did
that really sort of for the bigger
documents that they had that were
difficult to transcribe and what I just
wondered to send the originals aside
from Hitler's intuition with that much
resistance did you develop any theories
about why an assassination attempt never
was successful it is you know the guys
in the resistance you can't but marvel
at how brave they were because if you
got caught and I have to say almost all
of them did at one point or another you
were looking at a pretty grisly death
but Hitler he just it's inexplicable
there was an individual that I talked
about in the book by the name of George
Elser who was in 1939 he invented up
lots where he was going to blow Hitler
up this story kind of illustrates just
how lucky Hitler was he was going to
blow up this beer hall that Hitler was
speaking in and the guy was ingenious he
got a job in a construction factory and
her construction works and was able to
steal from dynamite which used for the
bomb and he was a carpenter and invented
a really accurate and sophisticated
timing device and he knew the date and
time
was going to be speaking in this beer
hall and so he would go into the beer
hole at night hide in the bathroom tell
everybody left he would come out with
his little tool box and he carved out a
kind of a hollow in one of the support
posts on the platform or Hitler was
going to speak he did this over several
days and put the bomb in there
everything worked perfectly but on that
particular night there was bad weather
in the munich area and hitler's pilot
said i don't think we can fly back to
Berlin you better take the train so
Hitler called off his speech a little
bit early just you know 10 to 15 minutes
early the bomb went off exactly as timed
with a tremendous explosion you killed a
number of people when the roof collapsed
Hitler would have been killed but it was
just a matter of bad weather there I
mean I could go on and on about similar
just inexplicable I'm twist of fate that
it's paired Hitler was incredible
everybody else since there's nobody else
one more question do you have a sense
for if the July 20th or any of the other
plots against Hitler had succeeded would
have that hastened the end of the war I
think yeah I'm sure so because the
people who wanted to replace Hitler were
very keen to end the war I think they
probably despite the protests from
Roosevelt nearness is all this is kind
of the fun of history playing the what
if game but I think that the Americans
if Hitler had been replaced and a new
German government came and said let's
let's quit this nonsense but it's hard
to an Americans you know to imagine any
American government to you know turn to
cold-shoulder to those kinds of offers
you know it's nothing you know it's hard
to imagine otherwise that the war
wouldn't have ended much more quickly
and just all of these you think it would
have been something other than an
unconditional surrender in that case you
know there's a lot of theories that
Dulles was kind of with a wink and a
nudge was telling the Germans just that
that is America's stated policy that we
will not negotiate with you but there
was there's actually was a document from
a German source that the claim that
Dulles had told them you know you guys
get rid of Hitler and I'll see that you
guys are looked after so I think you
know politically how could you continue
with the war if you had people who were
you know saying hey we got rid of Hitler
we hate him we want to be your friends
now how do you say no we're going to
fight you to the bitter end
it's the targa mountain otherwise but
it's fun to talk about
preferences
okay well thank you so much everybody
enjoy talking to
[Applause]
and then folks just a reminder there is
a book signing one level up at the
archives bookstore fifteen percent off
on lecture day make sure you get you
[Music]
Oh